hey guys it's dense offender thick hair
and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of agents of shield
episode 9 yeah repairs well it's already
episode 9 badges the time flies watching
the show yeah last episode we thought
like hey this is a decent episode step
the right direction this one like I
actually have mixed feelings about this
one it's not as good as last week's the
storyline I didn't really care about but
there were some character moments any
banter between the characters that I did
like yeah Jed Whedon co-wrote this once
was a little bit better a little it was
a step back i think from last week's but
it wasn't by any means the worst episode
that we've seen yet uh I like how they
opened you know with Mina you know and
grant yeah post forget you got grant you
know that relationships still kind of
going like how she's she's kind of the
man or the relationship just yet this is
just like I'm gone you know I don't need
he comforted I love that so that was
ones i think the the best things of last
week's episode that relationship that's
interesting to me I like that well yeah
you have those moments you have the
moments between Fitz and Simmons doing
the pranks against each other yeah I
find out May did the last prank and you
know you had nice character development
of sky trying to figure out what what
maze kind of secret is of why yeah
calvary right yeah we don't get
everything but we do get something
because at first it was kind of money
that Fitz and Simmons was telling this
big elaborate grand or people that she
killed and yeah alright one gun and then
grant gave a version and Coulson which i
assume is not the full version but
probably the most accurate that you're
gonna hear intimated decides to divulge
what happened right right no it was good
so those moments were nice but then my
problem was I didn't care about the main
store anything about the ghost dude or
the girl that they thought was a mutant
and had telekinetic power I didn't
really care about any of that stuff they
tried to tie it in back to Thor with the
portals being open and but that it's
still you can't the thing is when you do
you can't just mention thorns back to
get a good response like Oh its
dimension Thor it's as good now as as
part of the Marvel mythology and it's
like you have to
again you have to do the character stuff
was far more interesting small character
moments that's what makes a show good
the mythology alone can't carry the show
yeah yeah you can't always tie
everything in I mean I like last week's
tie-in because it was it was you know it
kind of made mention of the movie or
what happened in the movie but then had
its own thing that was semi-related
right and i thought the action was
pretty cool in the last week's episode
where this one I didn't really I mean
except for me at the end was kind of
cool me fighting the ghost I was kind of
cool but other than that I didn't really
care much about that that particular
store the episodic right nature that we
keep harping on like come on let's get
let's think gets to something bigger and
brighter I mean this is episode 9 the
show is in full swing this is I doubt
the show's gonna change so drastically
in the next half but oh my gosh wouldn't
recognize to show anymore so what
worries me is I hope this isn't all we
can expect this is like this is the peak
I hope that we see some more improvement
some better progression but i don't know
i don't know how bet better the show can
get from here i hope it does i'm just
not sure if they can salvage this season
quite yet I mean there's potential I
mean shows can you know I've watched
shows where you know they were kind of
like this where they're very episodic
and there's lowly they start turning to
a bigger story line and then you know
everything moves towards that and right
only problem I see is we haven't even
seen really a glimpse of that you know
that's what here because what you'd look
like they show like you're not talking a
lot about fringe and fringe had a slow
start but fridge had characters from the
beginning especially John Noble that I
cared about immediately as soon as he
was on screen I don't know if I cared
that much for the cast in marvel's
agents of shield III like me yeah I like
grant they're trying to develop him a
little bit more Fitz and Simmons or
trying to develop a little bit more but
there's still nothing sky I dont still
care for I don't care for as many
characters i did on fringe well fringe
also had massive dynamic i mean there
was a whole story of William Bell and
Walters relationship with him and this
storyline even though it was episodic
Lee tried to tie it in for that somehow
and then later it went that way
my problem with agents shield now is
what is that thing what is the main
where is the main villain what's it
they've given tiny tiny hints like some
girl in the flower dress and some guy in
prison and right um so next week's
episode maybe maybe will be better
because they're bringing back the actor
that was in the first episode who was
like who played gun angel he's coming
back he's if he joins a team he'll be
kind of like the the first superhero or
yeah or you know super-powered guy on
the team so hopefully this will give
maybe that's gonna build up their
overall story I don't know why saying 10
episodes them to do this but hopefully
before we get our you know our break our
mid season break there will be a bigger
story line to follow look forward to at
least a coming like whenever that
mid-season finale is it really delivers
it is too because I have a feeling if it
doesn't most people aren't gonna come
back yeah football for the show right
people are still like I get comments all
the time like why are you still watching
it and the ratings are dropping yeah and
a lot of times though I can guarantee a
lot of them haven't seen any of the
latest episode not to say that I you
know I like to disagree or anything but
I'm just holding out hope because of the
people who are buying it yeah not just
Joss Whedon cuz we know he's not you
know he kind of oversaw in the beginning
and then put ya down his jaw there
Fletcher from to Spartacus guys I mean
hopefully yeah so I I still have hope I
have a feeling maybe the network and
Disney and whoever the powers that be
are kind of holding them back all right
right now and then now as the ratings
are going low they're like all right do
what you want so yeah I mean if this
show just goes free form it could be
good yeah it could be more like maybe
like an arrow or something I think this
show because of the Cinematic Universe
they are being held back because the
Cinematic Universe comes first before
the television show they'll be curious
to see what the Netflix series are gonna
be like some see alright guys so that's
what we thought the episode you can post
your comments below on the website think
you're calm or on our YouTube channel
think hero pro and make sure you
subscribe to that as well I also come
check us out on Twitter we'll talk to
Dennis and I about you know my
relationship she liking it
you know have you given up on a long
time you probably still saying like why
you guys watch the show let us know your
feelings you can find us at think hero
i'm at griffin de and we have saw the
facebook page that's facebook.com slash
think carroll fans and make sure you
like that page and also tweet out and
share our videos on facebook and other
social networks thanks